luisiana comenzó un largo y difícil
camino hacia la recuperación tras el
paso del poderoso huracán la hora hay
ciudades inundadas y comunidades sin
servicios básicos como agua potable o
electricidad
los residentes de lakers regresaron para
ver lo que quedó de sus hogares acabo de
volver a la ciudad hoy solo para echar
un vistazo a las cosas y mi casa está en
muy mal estado pero seguiremos el paso a
la vez pieza por pieza vamos a volver a
juntarlo todo revisando la comunidad la
hora tocó tierra con vientos de hasta
240 kilómetros por hora más fuertes
incluso que los del huracán katrina de
2005 es el 2020 que se puede hacer la
mayoría de las muertes fueron producto
de árboles que se estrellaron contra las
viviendas o por envenenamiento con
monóxido de carbono debido al mal uso de
generadores eléctricos sin embargo el
daño es menor de lo esperado no quiero
minimizar la en absoluto es una tormenta
terrible mucha gente ha perdido muchas
cosas pero estamos agradecidos
que no se haya inundado y no estamos
haciendo rescates de agua rescates de
agua rápida o cosas de esa naturaleza
se estima que 8.000 viviendas fueron
destruidas y más de 14.000 personas
buscaron refugio en la cruz roja y otros
organismos